could other laws such as legislation
legalizing same-sex marriage be under
threat joining us is sir robert buckland
the former solicitor general for england
and wales he's also a barrister and a
conservative mp thank you for joining us
hopefully you'll be able to demystify
some of what's going on for us talk us
through first of all in a broad brush
the implications of this landmark
finding
well the finding of course uh is the
united states supreme court that's the
the chief appeal court in the united
states what it was all about really kaye
was the absence of a federal law
to regulate abortion and to allow
abortion uh for women right across the
united states congress has never passed
a law and the supreme court about 50
years ago in the famous case rowan wade
said in essence there was a
constitutional right that underpinned
the right to have an abortion
this landmark decision was pretty bold
it overturned that
decision it said that there isn't a
constitutional right to abortion and
therefore it's up to congress to
legislate on this or for individual
states to decide
uh hence the real concern that many
women across the united states indeed
across the world have shown about
the lack of access to abortion services
in many parts of the u.s so we're going
to spend quite a bit of time you know 15
20 minutes trying to unpack this so that
it's clearer for people as a result
because you know as we saw from that
debate there are very strong emotions on
either side of that debate as of today
what does it mean for a woman in the
united states who feels that she wants
to have an abortion well there are
certain states in the u.s chiefly in the
west and in the northeast which do have
abortion laws that allow abortion within
certain limits that will continue there
are a number of states that have as a
result of this decision already moved to
restrict abortion and it seems to me
looking at a map of the united states
there are large swathes of the country
now where women would have to travel
great distances and probably a great
expense
to have an abortion that in my view does
endanger lives it does cause real
concern and misery for many many people
and i think it's up to congress now the
legislature in washington to actually
get on and do the job that of course we
did in our house of commons and
parliament 50 years ago with the
abortion act and we will come to that
but i just want to uh unpick a little
bit more about what's happening in the
united states a lot of laws and
precedence of course in the us are
interlinked
even acknowledged by uh conservative
justices look at this one clarence
thomas in future cases we should
reconsider all of the court's
substantive due process precedence
including griswold which is granting
rights to contraception lawrence that's
decriminalizing um sodomy and uh
obergefell i think legalizing same-sex
marriage what does that actually mean
well
it's about a big argument between
different views of the u.s constitution
uh judges like clarence thomas
conservative judges take a much more
strict interpretation of the
constitution and don't like to see it
being stretched in a way that they think
defies its true meaning now there are
other judges so-called liberal judges
who take different views and want to
make sure that our society involves the
constitution involves with it that's one
of the perils k of having a written
constitution which of course was
originally written what 250 years ago
amendments this particular member the
14th amendment is the one that they
really obsess about passed just after
the u.s civil war it will tell you about
how a written constitution can be a
wonderful thing but it can also really
be a minefield for lawyers and a field
day for for the sort of arguments that
we see developing in the u.s so so where
is that leaving us robert as far as
things like same-sex marriage are
concerned in the united states and
contraception is it opening the door to
potentially finally a problem with that
as well well where there isn't a federal
law about it then the us supreme court
is often involved you know the supreme
court can strike down laws as
unconstitutional but where they sort of
get involved and are asked to be
involved in effect to legislate and to
create rights then this sort of problem
will occur time and time again and i
think it's really important that those
who are elected to public office in the
u.s at federal and state level actually
pass laws and debate laws
that then create
legal rights for people whether it's
same-sex marriage gay rights and indeed
the other swathe of rights that of
course are underpinned in our country by
legislation passed in parliament yeah
whereas as you're saying in the united
states if the u.s supreme court judges
our polit political appointees are they
well yes okay and we've all seen the
spectacle of the appointments process
where judges are asked about their
perceived political opinions and we get
this you know are you a conservative
judge are you a liberal judge now when i
was lord chancellor that was something i
really guarded against because i don't
think judges should be appointed as to
their politics they should be appointed
us to their legal merit and the quality
of their judgments and i think in the uk
we are very lucky to have judges who
aren't there because they're political
they're there because they're good
lawyers
so that's the situation in the u.s a lot
of women and men have been saying to me
could what happened in the u.s happen
here in the uk because few people know
that
abortion is illegal
you're right kate that there is a
criminal offence of procuring an
abortion either by yourself or by
somebody else that's a act of parliament
passed back back in 1861 it's section 58
of the 1861 offences against the person
act uh the number of prosecutions
brought under that act of very few i was
looking back through the records there
was one uh case brought in northern
ireland against an individual who had a
suspended sentence that's because uh she
wasn't able to access abortion services
in northern ireland that that at that
time
which we'll
so my view is twofold i think i think
having better access to uh clinical
abortion and safe abortion services and
safe family planning services is what
women need and deserve
but secondly the law i think could do
with updating i think it's important
that we keep a law to criminalize those
who might force women into an abortion
or might procure it you know we have
coercive controlling relationships and
domestic abuse one can imagine you know
that sort of thing potentially happening
horrific though it is but i don't think
the pregnant woman herself should be
criminalized
what does the law say
what does the law actually say well i
mean
it talks about an offense of procuring
an abortion either by administering
drugs or um
using implements frankly it's very
archaic language as you can imagine for
the 19th century at the moment women
themselves are criminalized
i don't think that that
is right i think that we should keep the
the law of procurement to deal with uh
individuals who might be pressurizing
women and forcing them into a position
of having an abortion but i think the
pregnant woman herself should not be
criminalized and
the pregnant woman who wants an abortion
needs the um signatures of two doctors
yes and that's up to 24 weeks yes and
after 24 weeks that doesn't count unless
there are other um
reasons for that abortion to go ahead
yes that's right as i was saying the
abortion act is now what 50 plus years
old uh it's applied in england and wales
and indeed in scotland as well for many
years it's only now in northern ireland
that we're seeing the law change to
remove the restriction on abortion that
applied there up until in fact this year
what's the situation in northern ireland
well no women in northern ireland will
be able to access uh abortion services
the law is broadly the same if anything
it's slightly probably more liberal
actually now in northern ireland than it
is on the mainland of great britain uh
however the important point here is now
we have a situation unlike the u.s where
women do not have to travel between
different parts of our country to
gain access to abortion services and i
think that is right we've had a few
questions from viewers about members of
the government who are openly uh opposed
to abortion come on to that in just a
second you are a christian
how do you feel about it well i do
believe that life begins at conception
but i think that to
sit in judgment on the situations many
women often very young women face the
difficult choices they have to make is
not for me to do and i believe therefore
the law should allow access to services
that can preserve the well-being of
young women and their future lives and
allow them that option of an abortion if
necessary and where appropriate i think
that we've got the balance right
where does um same-sex marriage uh fit
with your christianity
well i mean ten years ago i took a view
that whilst i strongly supported civil
partnerships for everybody i
was at that stage concerned about the
concept of marriage and whether we were
stretching it beyond definition
i think i got that wrong okay i think
that having seen uh what has happened
since the law has changed and seen the
the uh the joy actually that many
couples same-sex couples now can share
through marriage i think it's been a
revelation to me and i think it's
something that i would know strongly
support i think faithful relationships
sealed by a marriage are a wonderful
thing and that love is love whatever
type of love it might be so politicians
can change their mind however some um
choose perhaps not to jacob reese mogg
for instance back in 2017 he says he's
completely opposed to abortion
abortion is morally indefensible life is
sacrosanct and begins at the point of
conception and asks whether he uh
opposes whether the opposition i should
say applies in cases of pregnancies
resulting from rape or incest he said
i'm afraid so if you have people with
views like that in government is there
any person um who feels that you know it
even if you've been raped
or incest you still must go ahead with
the pregnancy well i i don't agree with
jacob about that i do believe that life
begins at the point of conception but i
do think that to ask a woman who's been
the victim of a horrific crime of rape
and having prosecuted many of those
crimes and met victims i have had
first-hand experience of what it does to
people
i don't think it's right for us to sit
in judgment
and in effect to force people into a
situation that was not their choice and
the important point here is that of
course jacob is a member of the
government we serve together in cabinet
it is a conscience issue for mps it's
not a party issue when we vote on these
issues in the house of commons it's on
our individual consciences and i think
that that's that's the right system to
have it means that uh the pressures of
the whips disappear and that one is left
alone thinking about these things guided
perhaps by the views of constituents and
others i i one is able to make a
considered opinion it's jake and i do
not agree on that however there are many
other issues that we do agree on uh and
um you know our moral consciences will
hopefully guide us when we uh may cast
those important votes yeah there will be
some concern though from viewers
watching this morning that if jacob
reese openly says what he said there
will be others within government within
cabinets who will agree with him but not
potentially as openly as he has spoken
for now um should they be at all
concerned people watching at home that
we could find ourselves in a similar
position to women in america i think
it's highly unlikely uh i i think that
uh the views of the prime minister are
well known uh as are many other members
of the cabinet uh i don't see that sort
of wellspring of view in within my party
or indeed any part of parliament to
overturn what is now very settled
legislation uh which
i think is largely working well i think
the situation in the u.s is dramatically
different because people do not enjoy
the protection of primary legislation
passed by its congress and that's what
congress needs to do well the reason i
asked you is because stella christie uh
was speaking in the guardian newspaper
yesterday i'm not sure if you saw it
most women in the uk do not realize
abortion is not a right as we said but
there is only a law giving exemption
from prosecution in certain
circumstances what the us teaches us is
that we cannot be complacent about
entrenching those rights in law
well i i mean i i'm always interested in
what stella has to say we do collaborate
on a lot of issues involving women um i
i i what i'm taking from her comments is
that she seems to be suggesting that
perhaps there needs to be further
entrenchment of abortion as a human
right um i respectfully would disagree i
don't think that's necessary the courts
cannot strike down primary laws passed
by parliament
they don't have that power in the uk
um i think it would take um you know mps
to change their mind to repeal laws for
the situation to change if she's asking
for you know a wider set of entrenched
rights i think that brings with it a
whole host of problems because the more
you start to create those sort of rights
the more you're inviting in effect
judges and the courts to come in and
interpret them and you know
inadvertently i'm sure she wouldn't want
this we could end up in a position where
we create a sort of u.s constitutional
court here in the uk and i think that
would be a very retrograde step i think
she might be referring to the british
bill of rights uh the human rights act
is set uh to be replaced with a british
bill of rights that's certainly what uh
the now justice secretary was looking at
last time he was on the programme
is your government
i don't know whether you agree not
allowing a loosening of human rights in
the uk
i don't think it is i think that many of
the changes in that bill are ones that i
would have brought forward because i
started the process of review and
updating of the human rights act which
is now over 20 years of age i think
there's a risk that we start confusing
things by uh in effect defining certain
issues whether it's jury trial which i
strongly believe in having prosecuted
and defended
cases
whether by enshrining and elevating
those particular rights people are going
to say well if you're doing it for that
why aren't you doing it for something
else and i think this bill is going to
be vulnerable to a number of amendments
on that basis and as conservatives as a
conservative i think we've got to be
very careful
about preserving our common law our
statute law and the unwritten
constitution of the uk and i don't want
to see a sort of you know
domestic set of rights that we create
with good intentions that only so more
confusion
so what you're suggesting is by not
having the constitution like they have
in the united states that that makes us
actually freer rather than more limited
i think so i think the tradition
in our country is that we've been free
to do
everything that's not prohibited by law
if it's like a cricket pitch where
you've got the boundary which is defined
which is where the law
sits and within that we are free to act
as you know free citizens under the law
i think that's a far better system than
having prescribed rights that can be
interpreted by let's face it unelected
judges uh who then are drawn into the
political arena in a way that i think is
bad for the judiciary and very bad for
elected and democratic politics now this
conversation came about because i i
spoke to you because i was seeking your
guidance on what was happening in the
united states what the rules were here
and whether there could be um you know
some sort of fluidity between the two
and as part of our conversation you
talked to me about um
how um are you going to harvard to talk
about artificial intelligence now tell
me about that yes well i'm going to be a
senior fellow at the mossava romani
center for government at the harvard
kennedy school it's a part-time unpaid
role which i will be largely doing from
here in the uk
and i'm going to be uh doing research
into artificial intelligence and what it
means for the concept of justice itself
you know okay in china
the chinese authorities are now using
algorithms to decide cases so instead of
having a judge
ai is deciding cases wow that's a big
thing and so far we've been looking at
it from a technological point of view
but i think there's an ethical dimension
here surely you know the the power of ai
is immense it can liberate us in ways
that perhaps we don't even fully
understand but here's the thing if we
don't start to set rules now about what
it can't do
we we might find that we're behind the
curve and that we've lost control of
this and i don't know about you but i
want to know who programmed the
algorithm what goes into the algorithm
what then influences it as it develops
and if it starts to take on if you like
a life of its own which is not
inconceivable in the near future what
does that mean for justice uh is it is
it one human being sitting in judgment
one or another or are we being judged by
forces that ultimately become beyond our
control i know sounds good we find that
happening here well
ai is already being used to help with
legal research and to look at documents
and to prepare complex cases i think
that's very
innovative and powerful and i think
digital technology is where we need to
be
but
i think that before we embark any
further on you know the encroachment of
ai into justice processes we need rules
and i think we need international rules
because if we're recognizing judgments
from abroad
are we recognizing judgments that aren't
actually the product ultimately of a
human mind and i think these questions
need answers and that's what i'm going
to be helping to lead in my work with
harvard kennedy school amazing we're
almost out of time like 30 seconds to
the end of the show i just wondered if
you had a thought on the scottish
referendum second in the ref 2 what do
you think well i think it's interesting
that nicolas sturgeon's taking it to
court even before she's passed uh
an act of parliament i suggest she's
probably pessimistic that she's going to
be allowed to have the power to have
this referendum a general election is a
general election it's not a referendum
and any attempt by her to pretend
otherwise i think is bogus
how interesting fascinating thank you so
much for taking the time to indulge us
with so much of your time thank you